hey this is Mel strong and this lecture
is on global circulation patterns and
what we're going to do is we're going to
take a lot of the things that we learned
about weather from the previous lectures
and kind of combine them all together
and look all around the earth and notice
that there are certain weather patterns
that we see in certain areas so we're
gonna start with Earth cool Schoolnet
and we're going to look at surface winds
at first so that's what I've got up here
right now
the colors represents wind speed so the
green means the winds are going a little
faster blue means the winds are going a
little slower and I'm gonna zoom in here
along the equator
okay so we're out here in the Pacific
Ocean and that line right there is the
equator and what we see is that we've
got winds that are coming up here
they're coming down from the Northeast
and from down here they're coming from
the southeast and they both kind of
flatten out and in turn almost exactly
from the east kind of in this zone right
here okay and if we go over and look at
let's say the Atlantic Ocean so again we
see I was oome in a little more here so
again that's the equator so we've got
winds coming up from the southeast and
they kind of flatten out and turn almost
perfectly due east here and then we have
wind's coming from the Northeast coming
through here so the big picture that we
see along the earth pretty much every
day is that there's this zone of winds
along the equator that are coming from
the east
maybe north east maybe south east and so
we call these winds the easterlies all
right so all these ones you see here
which have an easterly component are
called the easterlies also known as the
trade winds also known as the trades
okay so I'm gonna zoom back in here
and notice that if we have winds that
are traveling from the southeast and
ones that are traveling toward from the
Northeast they are both on a collision
course and you can see right in here
right through there they they are
running into each other in other words
they are converging and if I look over
here in the Pacific
I can see something similar let me go
right over in here so that line right
there is our equator and we've got winds
coming down from the Northeast ones
coming up from the southeast and they
are colliding with each other along this
zone right through here so that's called
a convergence zone and in fact this
whole area where it winds from the
southern hemisphere and winds from the
northern hemisphere are coming together
near the equator and converging that's
called the Intertropical Convergence
zone okay now I'm gonna go back and
forth between that animation and this
drawing here that I'm going to make so
right now what I've got is I'm trying to
draw the earth big circle and I've
sketched in the equator here so what I'm
gonna add to this is what we're what we
just saw so we've got winds that are
coming down from the east and they are
converging and they're not doing it
right on the equator but we're kind of
close to the equator this zone is called
the I T C Z enter tropical convergence
zone so this is happening all along the
equator I'm not going to draw it all the
way across but you get the point so if
you've got winds that are coming from
the north ish and winds that are coming
from the south ish and they're they both
have a they're coming from the east then
they're going to combine and collide
they've got to go somewhere right if
you've got two sources of one coming
together
and they hit each other they can't go
down so the only option is to go up now
what that does let's go back here and
I'm going to change this to temperature
and so now we so the colors now
represent temperature and you notice
that we have this band of really warm
water which is represented by this
orange color all along this area that
we're calling the tropical Intertropical
Convergence zone all the winds in that
orange zone sort of have a easterly
trajectory right they're coming out of
the east and we see this over here in
the Atlantic okay so so we've got really
warm water and then we've got winds that
are converging and then if I go and look
at total precipitable water we've done
this before in the previous lecture we
see that there is a band a really high
humid high dew point air air that's
really high in humidity so these these
aqua colors would represent air with
really high mixing ratios or dew points
so we've got air that's warm it's very
humid and you've got converging winds
and all of those things mean that this
wind when it converges has to rise and
when the draw that kind of coming off
the edge of the earth out into space
here and they're the perfect conditions
for making convective weather
cumulonimbus so I'm gonna draw a big
cumulonimbus now I am greatly greatly
exaggerating the size of this thing
because if this was true to scale the
entire atmosphere would be the thickness
of this line right so I'm just doing
this for illustration so when winds come
together in the convergent zone they
have to go somewhere so they go up and
they go up through this cumulonimbus and
if you remember back when we talked
about layers of the atmosphere they
it rises until it hits the tropopause
but so the stratosphere is above here
and then they curve and some of it moves
north so some of it moves south and
we'll talk more about that in a little
bit so we got perfect conditions along
the ITCZ
to form cumulonimbus and we can see the
effects of this in a couple different
ways so for one thing I'm going to go to
this is the world view site that we've
seen a couple times now and just to
remind you there are two satellites that
orbit on the opposite sides of the
planet at all times and they make these
images by taking stripes at each
satellite makes and they stitch them
together and the satellites miss a
little bit here in the middle that's
black right okay so look at the big
picture here I see that right here right
through there there's this kind of band
of white and I'll zoom in a little bit
so these clusters that you see they're
kind of roundish these are all giant
clusters of cumulonimbus this is where
the ITCZ is occurring today and it's
occurring right around their own zoomin
over here
and you can see a zoom in a little bit
that's the ice coming from the anvil
right so you've got a big cluster
cumulonimbus here and the fuzziness is
the ice from the anvil that's kind of
floating off okay so that's one way we
can look at it I'm gonna change my tool
and right now I'm going to look at
Google Earth and I'm looking at the
Google Earth cloud layer and this uses a
different type of technology to show
clouds and for one thing there's a lot
less clouds here
to look at and so what we're looking at
here is something called an infrared
image so let me explain what that mean
what that means
so clouds imagine we've got the ocean
and we were thinking if we think about
the
pictures of the tops of the clouds okay
we got a bunch of stratocumulus let's
say maybe we've got some fog the tops of
the temperatures of those clouds are
going to be fairly warm compared to the
tops of really tall clouds I
cumulonimbus right so if you had a
satellite that's up here and it's going
around the earth looking for
temperatures and it's measuring the
temperature say of this cumulonimbus
it's going to see a very cold
temperature whereas if it looks at the
bottom I'm sorry the tops of the strata
cumulus clouds
it's going to see a much warmer
temperature so these satellites as
they're going over they're actually just
measuring temperature these are called
infrared images and one of the
advantages of taking pictures of clouds
in the infrared is that you don't need
daylight so you can see them in the dark
and the other advantage is that if
you're just interested in the cold areas
that means you will only get these cold
cloud top temperatures in the settle it
will ignore all of this stuff okay so
that's what's happening here in Google
Earth what we're looking at are places
where the clouds are very cold which
means they're very tall right so we're
we have managed to filter out all the
low-level clouds so we kind of see here
there's a band so we're going across the
Indian Ocean here we see a band of these
white blobs a bunch of them here in
central Africa and these are giant
clusters of cumulonimbus along the ITCZ
and you have to realize how big these
things are like this thing right here
would be the size of several large US
states right if this thing was on let's
say we just pick this up and put it over
the middle of the country United States
it would be breaking all kinds of
precipitation records eV and they're
gonna get several inches of rain out of
each one of these blobs that you see
here and this is happening every day
along the equator along this itcz zone
and zoom out a little bit okay so it
kind of falls apart there but then it
comes back a lot of activity here over
Central South America and we don't have
it's not very well-established today but
many days you'll see a string of
cumulonimbus across the Pacific kind of
right in here and it varies day to day
so the actual activity of the ITCZ
varies day to day so today it looks like
you can see it quite a bit over there
central South America Central Africa
also notice why I've got Africa up
notice that northern Africa very very
dry very Brown south tip of Africa very
dry very Brown Central Africa very green
and the reason is that it's the central
part of Africa resides in the ITCZ
so they get these tremendous
thunderstorms
you know I said almost every day or they
get inches of rain at a time so let's
return to our drawing here and we can
add in I'm going to add in a bunch of
circles to represent these cumulonimbus
right all along the equator here in this
end of tropical convergence zone so
these again extend all the way around
the equator I'm just not going to draw
them all we can also see some other
evidence from this and we're going to go
back to earth little Schoolnet and one
of the things I'm going to do now is I'm
going to change this to three HPA which
means three hours of precipitation
accumulation so this map is showing the
colors now our precipitation has fallen
in the last three hours and there's a
couple patterns here first one to to
talk about what we were just looking at
the ITCZ see this band right here going
right through them right kind of along
the equator that's
itcz those are all blobs of
precipitation that are from cumulonimbus
here it gets it's pretty broad here and
there's just it kind of splits into two
but then if you go back Pacific Ocean
there's kind of a narrow band there all
those are little little blobs you know
cumulonimbus makes a fairly narrow blob
of precipitation right so that's what
we're seeing now while we're at it we
can see some totally different types of
precipitation see that you know what
that is so that's that classic commish
ape that's a mid latitude cycle and
that's the precipitation that was
produced in the last three hours from a
mid latitude cycle and you can see the
counterclockwise swirling of the wind
there's another one that's a little
harder to see but it kind of has a comma
shape that's the mid-latitude cyclone
this is another one that's a weird shape
and if you go around the world we can
see more of those comma shaped things
those are the mid-latitude cyclones but
for now what we're talking about is the
activity along the equator along the
ITCZ also I'm going to change the
overlay to mean sea level pressure MSL P
and so to remind you purple means
low-pressure the whitish color means
high pressure and back when we talked
about this I did this before when when I
showed this to you and I said that
notice that there is a purplish band
around the equator and this is due to
the fact that air is rising every day
along the equator now you and I use this
as an example of a thermal low it's so
warm the dew point is so high that you
get convection every day and that
produces lower pressure at the surface
so we can see it on this one pretty well
over the Pacific on this day a big band
a fairly low pressure so I'm going to
add that and I'm going to add some ELLs
here to remind myself that this is
a band of low pressure so again these
features are all the way around the
earth
you've got converging winds you a
cumulonimbus you've got low pressure all
these things I'm destroying them as
little chunks here but they would go all
the way around the earth okay so if the
air rises in again this is happening all
the way around the earth where you have
these rising plumes of air that turn
into cumulonimbus and then that air hits
the stratosphere and it can't go into
the stratosphere because the
stratosphere has this big temperature
inversion it has to go somewhere so some
of it goes north some of it goes south
now as it goes north and south and again
I'm greatly exaggerating the height
above the ground right just keep that in
mind it travels for a while and it it's
cooling it's radiating energy out in the
space and it starts to cool and then it
starts to come back down and both north
and south cut the air that rose at the
equator tends to come down right around
more or less 30 degrees north and 30
degrees south so I'm going to put down
30 degrees and then there's another zone
30 degrees south or this also happens so
let's think about and I'm just going to
basically ignore the southern hemisphere
but just realize that everything we're
talking about today up in the northern
hemisphere is happening also in the
southern southern hemisphere so here we
have sinking air so what does sinking
air do so if you have air sinking down
from the upper parts of the atmosphere
that produces high pressure along the
surface right so right here where this
air is sinking you would expect a high
pressure and in fact if this pattern is
happening all the way around the equator
you also have air that is sinking all
the way around the 30 degree mark so you
would have a band
and you would expect a band of high
pressures going all the way across now
we have a name for these they are called
the sub tropical highs a the subtropical
highs so if the earth was completely
water and there is no continents there'd
be a lot more symmetry to the patterns
we're talking about we have a perfect
band of cumulonimbus around the equator
every day we'd have a perfect band of
high pressure right around 30 degrees
every day but what actually happens is
you've got continents and the continents
heat up quicker during the day than the
oceans and that tends to send air up and
that tends to fight off say this high
pressure so what really happens is this
height that I'm drawing as a band it
kind of breaks up into certain zones
over the ocean and I'll show that in a
minute but just for now let's just kind
of continue this week this band of high
pressures is expected around 30 degrees
north and 30 degrees south so this loop
that we have where air rises at the
equator and it goes 30 degrees north and
it comes back down now this loop is
called the Hadley cell ok the Headlee
cell and this is one of the general
circulation patterns in the earth that
air generally rises from the equator
sinks back down at 30 degrees north and
30 degrees south okay so when air is
sinking makes a high pressure what
direction does the wind blow around a
high in the northern hemisphere goes
clockwise right so you can imagine that
if I had one single high I would draw a
clockwise spiral around it but I have a
band of them so you have to kind of
imagine a whole bunch a clockwise
spirals
like this and these spirals that I'm
drawing to the north of the H combine to
form what we winds that are coming
primarily from the West called the
westerlies and these are combining -
these are combining to provide what we
call easterly's alright so we've talked
about that's where we started is with
the easterlies now we can see that the
east rubies down here a part of a big
loop that formed when the air rose goes
to 30 degrees north 30 degrees south
sinks down in the northern hemisphere
makes high pressure clockwise rotation
around the highs and and the clockwise
rotation south of each one of these H's
combines to produce a band of wind that
we call the easterlies and to the north
a band of wind that we call the
westerlies so we're going to return to
our map of air pressure here so where we
left off we were talking about this
thermal low around the equator now to
orient yourself so there's the United
States is Hawaii notice what's this big
spiral out in the ocean here and another
one so clockwise rotation that's
consistent with a high pressure here's
another one high pressure
here's another one right around the same
latitude high pressure a little one
there okay so what we're seeing is we're
seeing high pressure blobs a high
pressure these are the subtropical highs
and again if the earth was all water we
would see a band of them all the way
across but what actually happens is they
tend to kind of form more over the ocean
basins and we see so a little bit here
in Europe I go the southern hemisphere
here's a bunch of in the southern
hemisphere that white blob that white
blob record you know
they're spinning in the opposite
direction because of the Coriolis effect
down there but you've got these blobs of
sinking air that are in this case
spinning counterclockwise and are the
neck of the woods spinning clockwise
these are set these subtropical highs
now subtropical highs tend to so they
tend to farm over the ocean basins and
they kind of tend to be found kind of in
the same place day to day so if we did
this tomorrow
we would notice that that big
high-pressure blob right there is still
there and day to day moves around a
little bit it might join forces with
that one then they split apart this one
also kind of moves around day to day if
we compared winter versus summer we
would see that they move quite a bit
more in the seasons but these these
subtropical highs are are very
consistent and so we give them names
this one right out here is called the
Pacific subtropical high so this is the
one that's parked right off the west
coast of the United States and you'll
notice that so right along the coast
it's actually under the influence of
these winds from this big spinning
subtropical high so the presence of this
high right off the coasts really affects
the weather on the west coast and in
fact it in could that includes New
Mexico this is a big blob of sinking air
if you have a big blob of sinking air
sitting right out here over the ocean
and it kind of bleeds over to the
continent that means that the west coast
and Baja California in Arizona and New
Mexico are all at times under the
influence of this big blob of sinking
air which means if you have sinking air
high pressure that fights cloud
formation that tends to make deserts
right so if you think about the climate
of what it's like over in here in the
Coffee desert a21 desert Arizona New
Mexico there why is it all so dry out
here well it's due to this Pacific
subtropical high so think about the big
picture here air has risen from the
equator makes cumulonimbus you can think
of it as like squeezing all the water
out from the cumulonimbus
so it's dry air then it goes north then
it sinks sinking air warms so now you've
got air that's fairly warm and really
dry and it then hits the ground and
produces high pressure so so if you live
under here anywhere under one of these
subtropical highs you'd expect to live
in a zone that's very very dry ok in New
Mexico is one of those places in Mexico
Arizona Southern California we're all
under the Pacific subtropical high so I
want to add on this with my band of h's
is that I'm gonna put down deserts ok
all all all along this band around 30
degrees or so you'd expect to find
deserts because of this consistent
sinking air from the Hadley cell so we
can look at the subtropical has a
different way and I am now back in
Google Earth looking at clouds again and
what I notice so there's California
right there I noticed that there's this
big area out here in the ocean where
there's no clouds now remember these are
infrared images so they only show tall
clouds so there could be fog or
stratocumulus something like that but no
tall clouds out here why is that that's
the Pacific subtropical high this whole
thing is a giant clockwise spinning blob
of high pressure sinking air fights
cloud formation so you see this big area
in the ocean where there's no clouds we
snow tall clouds or could go to the
southern hemisphere and right down here
it spins in the opposite direction beat
you it would be counterclockwise but
right here is another big blob
high-pressure seeking air from the
subtropical highs and again we see
almost no clouds no tall clouds are we
could go over here so again roughly in
the same area in latitude big blob out
here in the ocean no clouds
so subtropical highs areas of sinking
air that originated from the equator
produces high pressure and that in turn
fights cloud formation and if you live
under an area one of these under one of
these subtropical highs you're living in
a desert almost every time so let's look
for some westerlies now we're back
looking at surface winds the colors
represent wind speed and so here what I
see are a whole bunch of easterly's that
we saw previously right through here and
according to the diagram we've been
drawing we'd expect to find westerlies
kind of right through here but it
doesn't it's not real obvious here I see
this big clockwise spiral and that is
the Pacific subtropical high I've got a
couple counterclockwise spirals those
are a couple of mid-latitude cyclones
but nothing really looks like a wind
traveling from west to east like we just
drew so what I'm gonna do is change the
height and I'm gonna go to 700 millibars
700 millibars again is roughly somewhere
around 10 to 12,000 feet above the
surface and notice how different the
winds look up there so the colors again
represent
speed so when you see this those are
some really high speed winds I don't
know how high but I would not be
surprised if some of these in here were
100 miles an hour or something like that
so what we see it's look around the
earth here we can see that we've got
these ribbons of wind that are kind of
intermittent right so over here over
Asia you don't see them and then they
start over the as we go over the Pacific
and this one goes no
earth comes up into Alaska and then back
down and then fades away a little bit
comes back across North America and then
there's a bunch of little you know got
some mid-latitude cyclones in here as
well
but the point is that if I were to say
drop you off in a balloon okay I just
drop you off somewhere over here you
would get caught in one of these
currents and you be you know you go for
a ride for sure you might go through a
few loop-de-loops here and you know
there's chances where your path could
split one way or the other but
eventually eventually you would make
your way around the world from west to
east you know if you just stayed in
these streams long enough you'll
eventually make your way all the way
around the world back roughly where you
started
these are the westerlies okay so it
looks quite different than what we drew
and every day you look it's it's
different so if I let's just go back a
couple days here so go back a day back
another day
okay so just I'll stop right there so
now you can see how different it looks
here so there's our stream coming off of
Asia and now right we have a much
thicker band across North America it's
really sped up coming off North America
over the Atlantic you can follow these
streams over into Europe okay so every
day it's a little bit different but if I
kind of tilt the earth and look down the
North Pole in general what I would see
from the North Pole is this
counterclockwise circulation
you know there's exceptions to this but
again if I dropped you off in a balloon
you go around and around but eventually
you would make your way all the way
around the world and through these
following these different ribbons of air
and these are what we call the
westerlies now I'm going to go even a
little higher up to 500 millibars so now
this is roughly how high commercial jets
fly and so one of the things that you
see is that the winds are now much
faster and so you can see this
this ribbon right here that's really
fast this ribbon right here this very
fast you if you've heard the term
Jetstream these are jets okay so these
are these ribbons of high speed moving
wind that are in the westerlies and when
forecasters talk about the jet stream
this is what they're talking about now
if I go and change the overlay to
temperature okay so now the colors
represent temperature and if you think
back a lecture we talked about how
there's this pool of cold air up here
making these Rossby waves and we talked
about the polar front and the polar
front was this division between the
warmer air and the cooler air well this
high-speed wind this ribbon of
westerlies that were talking about kind
of follows the rows be waves so in other
words if I look over here or that one of
those jet streams were right through
there it's forming kind of right on the
boundary between the warmer air and the
colder air that's forming right along
that polar front so if you if you are
watching say a weather forecast and
they're talking about the jet stream and
they say well that jet stream it's
coming down into New Mexico okay well
the reason that's important is because
the jet stream typically follows the
polar front so if the jet stream comes
down over New Mexico that means this
blob of cold air is also dipping down
over New Mexico at the same time at
least the border of it is so they'll
talk about the jet stream from time to
time and weather forecasts mid-latitude
cyclones typically form along that
border like we talked about last time so
those are the westerlies now it's also
let's go back to go back to surface and
let's see let's leave it on temperature
for a bit or I can straight down the
North Pole I'm gonna zoom in here okay
it's not very well developed today but
right here I think you can kind of make
out there is a
clockwise spiral here and usually over
the North Pole there is a high pressure
with clockwise rotation right right
around there
and that forms a band of wind that we're
gonna call the polar easterlies they I'm
not very well developed here but let's
draw a few things on our diagram here so
here's our westerly so our polar front
we could just kind of say something like
this always changing
right but that's an abbreviation for our
approximation sorry for where it would
be so up at the North Pole then we've
got winds that are spinning clockwise
and they they're not very well developed
in today's animation there but you've
got a high kind of near the North Pole
with these winds that are coming down
this direction and so right here right
along here is where we talked about how
you get the formation of mid-latitude
cyclones right so you're mixing up this
cold air with this warm air and there's
a pretty abrupt transition so all the
warm fronts and cold fronts all that
stuff we talked about in the past that's
all happening right along that boundary
there okay so just to kind of fill that
out then warm fronts make air rise
because of the ramp remember that from a
previous lecture cold fronts make air
rise because the cold air tunnels
underneath so you have air that's rising
along the polar front okay because of
those two different types of frontal
systems mid-latitude cyclones which is
what you get when you mix up these two
types of air cause air to rise so some
of that air rises and then kind of
settles down along the North Pole okay
so there's a nut you know this is
happening all the way around you know
again this is happening all the way
around the earth here so it's not just
rising in this one spots all the way
we're
and sinking down around the North Pole
creating a high-pressure clockwise
rotation around a high you get these
winds that we call the polar easterlies
you can read that polar easterlies
alright so air is rising from mid
latitude cyclones this little loop here
is sometimes drawn and this isn't called
the ferrule cell and this is called the
polar cell and we're not really
emphasizing these two things the Hadley
cell is really the important one in this
class but you may see this from time to
time these two cells so what else do we
need on our diagram well the other thing
we could draw is those mid-latitude
cyclones are going to form right through
here as we mix up the air so I'm just
going to draw some kind of commish eight
things just to illustrate that that
that's where our mid-latitude cyclones
are going to form there
so
we kind of have a mess here but in
general this is the circulation pattern
of the Earth's atmosphere now let's look
at a couple of the movies here so this
one we're looking at a not just clouds
but also water vapor so the gray that
you see is water vapor they're really
bright white or clouds and each frame is
every three hours and you can see the
days go by up here okay so every three
hours
there's another frame and you can see
some of these features so right through
the middle there you can see the ITCZ so
it's just cumulus day after day after
day after day you can kind of see the
difference between day and night they'll
appear during the day then they
disappear at night over and over and
over
you also see see that counterclockwise
spiral there's another one these little
spirals that we get those are the
mid-latitude cyclones okay so you'll see
the counterclockwise spirals out here
mid-latitude cyclones the ITCZ down here
now in this image that the black is dry
air not near the surface but up in the
upper part of the troposphere and the
reason you have if you if you watch this
for a while you'll see that there's kind
of constantly this black right out in
here and that is our Pacific subtropical
high that's our sinking air from the
Hadley cell so that air coming down is
dry and you can see it gets mixed up
from time to time but it'll keep
reforming this dark ball the air that's
dry sinking air from the Hadley cell
very few clouds forming in this area
right because of that dry sinking air we
can also look at it the whole earth now
this one I made a little slower but it's
the same idea every frame is every three
hours there is a mid-latitude cyclone
there's a mid-latitude cyclone now down
here you've got them but they're
spending the opposite direction so that
one right there spinning clockwise
mid-latitude cyclone
okay we're getting fined another okay
here's another one you see these white
flashes that's a lot of times the
something happens when they download the
data off the satellite and they don't
get all of it so that's why it's
blinking like this so here and this
one's in the winter the last one was
starting in the spring and went to this
through the summer but again you can
kind of make out this is the ITCZ kind
of through here not as well formed as
the last movie you got mid-latitude
cyclones up here you got mid-latitude
cyclones down here ok so that's kind of
the global picture now if you see this
in a book it's always showing zone as a
much simpler thing so here's an example
of a text book out sorry an image out of
a textbook and what you can see is they
show okay here's the ITCZ is it's nice
perfectly straight line and then the
high is the subtropical highs are nice
perfectly straight line and there's the
trade winds and there's the westerlies
okay and then here's the de sel so this
is the Hadley cell the Farrell cell and
the polar cell there right so it's nice
and neat but one of the points I'm
trying to make is that it's not nearly
as nice and neat as you might read in a
textbook so here's another one this is
more three-dimensional so here they're
showing the ITCZ is this nice little
band of clouds there and then along the
polar front another band of clouds again
those are from the cold fronts and warm
fronts and in the oh there's the
westerlies but again it's not nearly
that nice if you averaged it over the
whole year it kind of looks like this
but as we saw in those movies it
definitely looks very chaotic right so
these are just average patterns averaged
over a long period of time so one of the
small scale things that can have a big
effect on your climate is the topography
especially when it comes to
precipitation so let's imagine this
scenario we've got this ocean and a
cotton
and we've got a storm that's coming in
and I'm going to draw my storm as this
little tiny baby cumulonimbus cloud but
it represents something much more
complicated like a storm system and it's
coming inland and so let's let's just
say it's raining it's raining out in the
ocean and when it hits the continent one
of the things that's going to happen is
that storm is going to intensify and the
reason for that is the continent is
usually warmer than the ocean so it's
good so the storms coming along and
suddenly it gets a little boost of warm
air from the continent and that makes it
grow right so it starts raining more but
now this storm has to go uphill now when
we talked about convection we said that
if you can make air go up air that moves
up expands it cools eventually hits the
dew point makes a cloud if it continues
to go up you can eventually make ice
creates precipitation right that's how
you get precipitation that whole process
what if you already have a storm and you
make the whole storm go up the storm
will intensify so this storm that I'm
drawing as it goes up the mountain will
grow and become stronger and stronger as
it goes and I'm again simplifying by
just drawing cumulonimbus clouds here
but as it goes up the mountain it
produces more and more precipitation as
it's forced further and further up right
okay so this is the storm going up but
what happens when the storm goes down
well sinking air fights cloud formation
take a storm and make it go down and the
storm will get weaker it's going the
opposite direction that it needs to go
so what happens is as it goes down the
hill it becomes weaker
however it's not exactly symmetrical to
the other side because it's now lost
some precipitation over here right once
it left the ocean it doesn't really have
a source of precipitate of
humidity anymore so as a precipitation
is occurring you can think of this
entire column of air the dew point is
going down as the air moves inland right
it's losing water as it goes so this is
not producing as much precipitation as
it did on the other side okay so this
means that if you were to go up the
mountain here you you would experience
more and more precipitation on the way
up so we have a wet side of the mountain
and then on the other side we see a side
that's considerably drier as it goes
downhill and gets drier and drier
towards the bottom something like this
and so by the time the storm gets to the
bottom of this hill it's this is the
driest point so far but now it's gonna
go back up alright so now it's gonna go
back up this next Mountain so once again
the storm intensifies now it's going to
rain more as it grows
and like the little Mountain it's now
the precipitation is going to increase
as it goes up the second mountain so now
we get another zone that increases with
height the wet zone right so we get that
now it comes down the other side and now
as before this storm is on its way down
and it weakens and it weakens a lot
because now it not only has lost all of
the precipitation coming up the first
mountain it also lost precipitation
going up the second mountain and now
it's got a long ways to go downhill so
this mountain this side of this mountain
that's going to be even drier on this
side than the first one so these
mountains have very different climates
you've got a wet side and a dry side a
wet side and the dry side this is called
the rainshadow effect the rain shadow
effect so if you live in a place where
there are mountains and there's a
preferred direction that the storms come
from you might live on the wet side or
you might live on the dry side and
you'll have a completely different
climates so this goes on a lot in the
western part of the United States so
this is a diagram out of a textbook
showing the rain shadow of effect as a
storm moves in over Washington State so
they come in over the Pacific go up the
Olympic Mountains which are on the on
the west coast so you they intensify as
they go up they weaken as they go down
you have a relatively dry spot here then
they go up the Cascade Mountains which
are chain of volcanoes and they
intensify on the way up and then dry on
the way down then this then it's pretty
dry as we'll see in a second across
Eastern Washington State and
eventually they get to Idaho in tune
Idaho they go up the Rocky Mountains and
intensify again and you get a little bit
more moisture before coming down the
other side and it's really dry again so
we can see this on a map of
precipitation of the US so these colors
represent annual precipitation here's a
scale down here and if we look over here
on the west coast we can see there's a
kind of a purple stripe right there and
another purple stripe right there and
those are two stripes of really intense
precipitation so storms come in so
there's Washington state so right there
that's the Olympic Mountains they come
ashore and intensify go up hill dump a
bunch of rain and how much rain are we
talking here so over 100 inches so that
white area 150 inches or so of rain
again this can also can fall as snow but
rain equivalent so if you are from New
Mexico you know 150 inches of rain just
does not compute to our brains so it's
hard to imagine that but you have all
this rain coming out on this mountain
range here it's the west and it goes
downhill you have a relatively dry spot
here they didn't goes up the Cascades
and you get another wet stripe so you've
lost precipitation here you lost
precipitation here and now the storms
are going downhill and suddenly
Washington State gets really dry
Washington State is a pretty extreme
example of the rain shadow effect it's
called the Evergreen State that's their
logo so over here it's rain forests over
here see those red colors that's the
same as most of New Mexico is actually
areas in eastern Washington state that
are drier than New Mexico so you've got
desert right next to rain forest not
that far apart that's the rain shadow
effect storms come down hill down the
hill and down the hill and then they
finally get to the Rockies they start to
go uphill again and you get
intensification over here in Idaho then
they go back downhill again and so now
it's really dry again over here in
Montana
so that's illustration of the rain
shadow effect
which really affects all of the western
part of the United States so you can see
this effect all the way down here in the
California we've got a lot of
precipitation on the in the western
mountains and then you've got a little
break and then here for example that's
the Sierra Nevada mountains same idea
the storms come in you know they hit the
coast they dump they get into Central
Valley that weekend they go up the
Sierra Nevadas they strengthen again
they come down the other side
now it's in rain shadow again so it's
super dry over here in Nevada you can
also see this on a bigger scale so if we
extend this map up into Canada and
northern territories here's this blue
stripe this is the wet west coast and so
even up here in Canada with it you know
this is all mid-latitude cyclones
they're coming in they're dumping
precipitation along the west coast here
and then as they move inland they it's
drier you get that rain shadow effect
and they have a very dry inland part of
the continent Oh another thing this
shows is that you can see where the
mid-latitude cyclones kind of stop so
during our summer mid-latitude cyclones
are coming across up here you know we're
not aware of them that's why we call
them winter storms but they're still
hammering the coast up here and then in
in our winter there they come down and
get down into right about the middle of
california that blue color disappears so
mid-latitude cyclones are rarer and
rarer the further south that you go okay
let's see here so let's look at a map of
just New Mexico for for a minute and you
can see that so there's the outline of
the state right you can kind of make it
out there and there's Albuquerque where
the X and you'll notice that Albuquerque
is really in almost a driest part of the
state there's a little bit something dry
right there but really this color this
orange color here it's among the driest
parts of the state so if you go in any
direction you'll run into parts of New
Mexico that are that are wetter okay so
why is this
well I'm gonna throw up another map here
of elevation and we can compare these
two things so Albuquerque is right in
here and this is the Rio Grande Valley
right it comes down through here and the
river is at the lowest elevation locally
so we live in a spot that's among the
lowest elevation in the state so if
you're a storm coming from the West you
gotta go downhill to get to Albuquerque
which means you're weakening as you go
downhill if your storm coming from the
north you're weakening as you go
downhill coming from the east or the
Northeast weakening as you come downhill
so no matter which direction a storm
comes
unless it's coming directly from the
south it's got to go downhill to get to
Albuquerque so it weakens as it
approaches us so this is what happens
all the time you may have had this
experience we have a winter storm
warning for example here I go boy maybe
it's gonna snow we'll have a snow day
tomorrow no school and you wake up in
the morning all excited and you look
around you see snow everywhere around us
but not here in Albuquerque why because
we are at locally a pretty low elevation
so that storm that may have dumped snow
all around us weakened as it approached
Albuquerque and you can see on this map
also that this the Rio Grande Valley
comes down this way so all of this is
really dry cuz it's a little elevation
and this blog right here right this is
pretty wet because this corresponds to
this mountain this little wet blog here
corresponds to this mountain this will
the what you know this wet blog right
there
corresponds to this mountain etc so
places that are a high elevation get
more precipitation for his storms are
forced up over them which enhances the
precipitation then they come down the
other side and they're dry again so
let's return back to this map and talk
about a couple more things so you talk
about rain shadow effect here this is
pretty dry down here and there's more
than one reason for that we do have lack
of mid-latitude cyclones they don't get
that far south we have rain shadow
effects so the ones that actually get
this far south lose their moisture on
the coast but we also have the fact that
we are under the influence of the
Pacific
subtropical high Pacific subtropical
high sits right out here out in the
ocean in influences this part of the
country kind of right in here Southern
California parts of Nevada Arizona and
New Mexico so the all those things
combine to make to give us a very dry
climate notice something weird happens
kind of right in the middle of the
country if we're a mid latitude cycle
and we're coming in and we dump our
precipitation on the west coast on the
mountain ranges and then we have that
rain shower to effect and it's pretty
dry then we come down out of the Rockies
then it picks up moisture and we see an
increase of precipitation and how could
that be well if you're mid latitude
cycle and coming across you've lost all
of your moisture as he came across here
if you think of it in terms of like dew
point of the air the dew point of the
air was the highest when it started and
you've lost water you've lost water
you've lost water all the way across so
you've got really low remaining dew
points when you get to here but if
you're a low pressure system and you
moved let's say into this part of the
state that part of the country if you're
a little pressure that means you got
counterclockwise rotation going around
here right so that means you can bring
up moisture say from the Gulf of Mexico
bring it in and we figure eight your
mid-latitude cyclone so mid-latitude
cyclone that's kind of all out of
moisture can pick up new moisture maybe
out of the Gulf of Mexico maybe from the
Atlantic and generate new precipitation
so that's why we see this half of the
country suddenly much wetter than the
western half of the country mid-latitude
cyclones can come in from many different
directions and we're not getting that
deep into it in this class they may come
down from the Northeast called a
nor'easter they may kind of drop in this
direction but they've got many moisture
sources out here that they can pick up
moisture from so overall there's a lot
more moisture that can generate a lot
more precipitation both in the winter
and the summer in the winter with
latitude cyclones in the summer
summertime thunderstorms they can pick
up all that high humidity air down here
we talked about the Tornado Alley that
really unstable
forming this part of the country in a
lot of summertime thunderstorms
so to summarize near the equator we've
got easterly winds there's some north of
the Equator there's some south of the
equator but they're on the collision
course usually and when they collide
they have the wind has nowhere to go but
up when it goes up it makes a
cumulonimbus cloud when the wind get
when the air gets to the top of the key
Melendez cloud he has nowhere to go I
can't go in the stratosphere so it goes
north and south and it spreads out along
the globe until it gets to about 30
degrees north and 30 degrees south then
at that point it sinks back down to the
ground down to the surface of the earth
that makes high pressure we call those
high pressure areas subtropical highs
that whole loop rising at the equator
moving 30 degrees coming back down
returning back to the equator eventually
that's called the Headlee cell now all
the winds north of the subtropical highs
are mostly coming out of the West the
West release most of the winds south of
the subtropical highs are normally
coming out of the east the easterlies
but it's not as simple as it is shown in
a lot of textbooks these winds are
changing all the time they're loopy they
have bends so the exact position and
direction of these winds changes day to
day in a previous lecture we talked to
all about the polar front and how we get
mid-latitude cyclones those are always
circling the planet all times of the
year there's some in the northern
hemisphere there's some in the southern
southern hemisphere now all of these
things that we've talked about create
different zones of climate we expect
certain types of weather on a normal
basis what is causing all these things
ultimately is the fact that the equator
is warmer than the poles and the earth
is trying to equilibrate is temperature
but you can also get other small-scale
things that affect your climate and the
one that we've talked about here is the
effect that topography has on
precipitation so if you live in one side
of the mountain it could be a whole lot
wetter they need if you live on the
other side of the mountain that's called
the rainshadow effect so
we're gonna do in the next lecture is
we're going to see how all these things
change with the seasons
okay so we've been talking about roughly
where they are well but next time we'll
talk a little bit more like how where do
things move in the summer where do
things move in the winter okay thanks
for watching
you